welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the marvel cinematic universe
has an official timeline keeper
according to the producers of shield a
series with such confusing chronology
that we have some questions for this
timeline keeper who i assume is just
going to blame kang as they should as
someone who has been doing my best to
keep track of the mcu timeline without
getting paid to do so by marvel i mean
they pay me to show their universe but
uh not to fix their timeline side note
to all the disney hater conspiracy
theorists who think that i am somehow
paid by marvel studios to show their
universe that is sadly not the case i
fix their plot holes for fun and i only
get paid if you buy our ridiculous
sponsors anyway in this video i shall
explain the discrepancies of the mcu
phase four timeline and kevin feige if
you are watching please consider this my
video application to be your in-house
chrono monitor if that position ever
opens one of those frequent questions i
get asked is about this playlist on
disney plus labeled marvel cinematic
universe in timeline order after
avengers end game it goes loki then what
if then one division then the falcon of
the winter soldier then chung chi then
eternals then doctor strange and
multiverse madness then hawkeye then
moon knight and recently she-hulk was
added here and then miss marvel oh and
by the way those five im groot shorts
were added around the guardians of the
galaxy movies which are set back in
2014. now you'll notice missing from the
disney plus phase four chronology are
spider-man far from home and spider-man
no way home which are sony
co-productions and they do not stream on
disney plus currently also heads up here
that the uh sony part of the production
of those movies often put stuff in those
movies that kind of mess up the mcu
timeline continuity that the marvel side
doesn't really bother to fix so end
game's main events and the final battle
take place in october 2023 it's a little
more than five years after the snap in
may 2018. now spider-man far from home
takes place after end game but also
would go after loki and probably after
what if as well because far from home is
really in the summer after end game
summer 2024 but loki is suggested to be
a timeline agnostic narrative spawning
from loki branching from the timeline
and end game in the year 2012 and then
the multiversal events of what if are
suggested to have spawned from the death
of he who remains in loki spider-man no
way home starts immediately after far
from home but its main events place it
probably between eternals and doctor
strange and multiverse madness peter's
spell crisis is set in early november
2024 right after halloween judging from
the decorations in mj's shop and this
being the time of year early decision
applicants typically hear back from the
colleges they apply to now there was
some confusion when multiverse of
madness was placed on disney plus before
hawkeye because we all assumed that
hawkeye was set in that same christmas
time 2024 period that no way home was
and multiverse of madness must take
place after no way home based on strange
and wong referencing a past incident
with spider-man but it still works when
you break it down because again no way
home is set in early november 2024
multiverse of madness is set in late
november early december 2024. hawkeye is
set mid to late december 2024 and then
the epilogue scene of no way home when
peter swings in his new suit during
christmas time is set around then
christmas 2024 so there's a bit of time
between the main events of no way home
in the very ending of no way home
actually peter's swinging around must be
before the hawkeye finale episode
because you'll notice peter swings past
the 30 rock christmas tree and it has
not yet been knocked over further
evidence that hawkeye is set in
christmas 2024 a set photo shows clint
kate and lucky the dog in front of a
sign that reads happy new year 2025. it
is a chinese new year sign year of the
snake and the chinese year the snake
begins on january 29 2025 so the chinese
restaurant might have just had to sign
out early now that actual year was
covered in the episode of hawkeye that
released on disney plus but the prop
indicates that someone working at marvel
this timeline keepa had this prop made
based on their internal records now
chongqi is obviously said after in-game
there were signs for therapy referencing
the blip and we can deduce at the movies
set during the summer time because there
were some signs on the san francisco bus
advertising a summer jazz festival so
this brings us to the timeline confusion
with shihokshan chi and ms marvel we
know she-hulk takes place after eternals
based on the reference to tiamat but
episode 2 of she-hulk ends with the
footage of abomination fighting wong in
the golden daggers fighting club in
shang chi leaking to the public but
chang-chi's poet's credit scene shows
bruce banner in human form suggesting
that that whole movie must take place
before she-hulk begins the shield begins
with bruce changing back to hulk form
she-hulk head writer jessica gao told tv
line that she-hulk is said after
shang-chi quote not too far not years
later it's a relatively short amount of
time the simplest explanation is that
whoever took this video sat on it for a
while before the footage made it to the
news media at least a few months based
on she-hulk episode 1's origin flashback
taking place a few months before the
main events of the series now i'm not
sure why this internet breaking footage
would take so long to get out there but
who knows maybe the golden dagger's
attendee was drunk when he took it he's
just been too distracted in an mcu
filled with freaking celestials to care
about uploading footage of forgotten
phase one bill into youtube are you into
she-hulk and house of the dragon well
i've got good news epic hero shop.com
has not won but two latest obsession
shirts available right now later to
session number 19 is lady justice and
latest obsession number 20 is ash and
ruin now they won't be around forever so
get them before they head down to the
dungeon to hang out with the theatrical
release of batgirl and if those teas
aren't enough to wet your targaryen
whistle epicurus shop's fire and blood
collection will fit the bill they've got
the rogue prince for the days that
you're keyed up realm's delight for the
days you just want to snuggle up with
the dragon and king maker for the days
you just gotta wear a shirt with a bunch
of dragons on it epic heroshop.com is
the place to get the most up-to-date
nerd merch remember in the first episode
of she-hulk when we found out that cap
they dropped this
shirt immediately finally a way to
celebrate the long-awaited tapping of
america's ass picking up a piece of epic
hero shop is the best way to support the
channel and it's so crazy cool and
amazing for us to see you guys wrapping
our merch we truly appreciate the
support and it actually makes us feel
like rock stars when we see one of our
shirts out in the wild so thank you and
be sure to tag at epic hero shop and use
hashtag real epic hero to get featured
on their page they geek out just as much
as we do but this connection with
shengchi is why i believe she-hulk was
positioned to take place earlier than we
expected before ms marvel because they
could not wait too long for that
abomination footage to stay buried we
actually learned that abomination's
return in she-hulk was the only reason
he was added as a cameo to shanghi so ms
marvel takes place either during or
sometime after spring 2025. how do we
know that ms marvel episode 6 included
an a sanitation grade sign and the food
truck dated march 14 2025 and later in
that episode in the high school
gymnasium past volleyball team
championship banners included one for
2024 meaning it would have been for the
previous fall season and these events
must be sometime after that meanwhile
miss marvel also includes a shot of the
statue of liberty with its normal green
color when spider-man no way home
supposedly set months earlier showed the
statue restored to its original
pre-oxidation copper color with a giant
captain america shield added though that
shield collapsed during the battle
maybe the statue rapidly re-oxidized in
the interview the months
more likely this is an example of the
sony folks putting something in their
movie that the mcu continuity team
either forgot about or just didn't want
to spend the vfx budget constantly
updating statue of liberty but by
placing ms marvel after she-hulk this
tells us that marvel studios might
consider its events more forward-looking
in phase 5 than the events of she-hulk
are or she-hulk jessica gao even warned
fans to keep their expectations in check
something i wish more phase 4 series
show runners and stars did look at you
paul bettany by comparison ms marvel
ended with a major mutant reveal and
kamala khan looping back in time in a
way that iman valani even confirmed to
me in an interview might have been part
of kang's plan do you think kang or he
remains might have planned specifically
for kamala to go back in time
yeah okay so the inscription on the
bangle used to be what is destined for
you will come for you we did change it
after that but i like to use that as a
way of you know justifying how kamal
goes back in time and why that was meant
to happen now obviously both jen walters
and kamala khan will return in phase
five and beyond specifically in
conflicts with kang and avengers kang
dynasty but i think the implication here
is that the way ms marvel ends
mid-crisis with kamala swapping places
with carol danvers is a direct link to
phase 5 stories like the marvels and by
comparison sheol might not end with as
immediate of a plot set up for the
future so now based on this timeline in
iman velani's statements i really do
think kamala's mutant status and her
going back in time are going to be a
huge deal to the mcu's plans going
forward a major violation of the sacred
timeline that kang or he remains for a
reason we will eventually learn allowed
kamala to do maybe even needed her to do
you can follow me on tik tok instagram
and twitter at avos subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you